mit breaking news sind wird so hierbei
bild live und mit der frage ist kanzler
olaf scholz ein ehrlicher mensch denn um
diese frage geht es jetzt in diesen
minuten es ist der schwierigste tag für
ihn und wir halten sie auf dem laufenden
was er in diesen minuten sagt denn ganz
deutschland erwartet die ganze wahrheit
von olaf scholz jetzt in hamburg in
diesen minuten also der kanzler im
kreuzverhör im sogenannten comex
untersuchungsausschuss diesem riesigen
steuerskandal und einsatz hier sehen wir
aus dem auto steigen eben erst hat das
ganze begonnen ist schon wieder gefallen
ich weiß es nicht wenn ich erinnere mich
nicht das ist der satz den man nicht
mehr hören wollte man will klartext man
will ehrlichkeit scholz soll jetzt alles
was er weiß auf den tisch liegen das
ganze spielt sich jetzt ab hinter
verschlossenen türen in hamburg wir sind
aber natürlich live dabei unsere
reporter sind live dabei es ist der wohl
wichtigste tag für bundeskanzler olaf
scholz und hier bei uns im studio ist
bild live chef claus strunz zur
einordnung wenn man muss sagen klaus
schön dass du hier bist es ist ein
wichtiger tag für olaf scholz an dem er
viel verlieren könnte vor allem
glaubwürdigkeit absolut es ist
tatsächlich der schwierigste tag von
olaf scholz hat schon eine lange
politische karriere hinter sich aber so
ans eingemachte wie heute ging es ja
selten dass gegen schlicht geht schlicht
und ergreifend um alles wenn er hier wie
ja in rede steht dazu beigetragen hat
informiert war womöglich empfehlungen
abgegeben hat das einem bankier in
hamburg wenn ich das richtig im kopf 47
millionen euro steuer erlassen werden
dann wird es einen anderen blick auf den
ehemaligen ersten bürgermeister von
hamburg und den jetzigen bundeskanzler
und dass er sich daran nicht erinnern
kann also das geht mir wirklich nicht
ein jetzt liegen ja durch die bild
recherchen auch hinweise darauf vor dass
die anderen beteiligten dieses gesprächs
sich schuld daran erinnern können und
sogar auch alles aufgeschrieben haben
was da war aber olaf stolz sagt er könne
sich nicht erinnern die erinnerungslücke
ist ein weit verbreitetes phänomen unter
politikern und ich will nur mal eine
frage stellen 47 millionen euro sind
auch für den bürgermeister in der stadt
viel geld vielleicht eine der größten
summe mit der man zu tun hat in der
namens periode das wäre also
vergleichbar dass man privat ein
geschäft ab schließt mit einer bank oder
dabei sitzt wie andere über ein geschäft
reden und seine meinung einbringen soll
sagen wir mal in unserem fall
über eine million euro also sitzt denn
dein leben dabei wo leute über eine
million euro reden und du sagst
hinterher also da kam mir niemand dran
erinnern würde es jetzt genau war also
seid mir nicht böse und hört endlich auf
mich zu beschuldigen ich hätte irgendwas
getrickst ich finde ja es gilt schon im
zweifel für den angeklagten
das geht aber es gilt auch im zweifel
für die bürger jetzt muss olaf scholz
sagen liebe deutsche hier ist ein
vorwurf gegen mich erhoben worden und
ich werde den heute ausräumen und mit
ich erinnere mich leider nicht räumt man
einen vorwurf nicht aus und das wird
heute eine interessante frage und ich
bin wirklich gespannt auf alles was
jetzt direkt aus hamburg zu unseren
informationen gelangt weil es eigentlich
auch auf jede silbe von olaf scholz
ankommt hinten sagt sie ja er sagt ja er
hätte die leise hoffnung dass die
mutmaßungen und unterstellungen jetzt
ein ende nehmen also erstellt sich
anstatt format zu beweisen die chance
hat in den vergangenen tagen auf gehabt
oft verpasst geht er in die opferrolle
absolut app und und ja fast schon in die
indy also dieser satz ist ja für olaf
scholz quasi die maximale attacke olaf
scholz ist ja das haben wir mal
zurückhaltender kommunikator stiller typ
war lang der scholzomat in
anführungszeichen wenn der sagt ich
hoffe jetzt geht das mal zu ende das
heißt auf deutsch gesagt haltet endlich
den mund ihr kritiker ihr habt nichts in
der hand und beschuldigt mich den
bundeskanzler etwas schlimmes getan zu
haben das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr mit
eine fahne verteidigung wendet aber
normalerweise jemand an der befürchtet
dass wenn in sein die wirklichkeit nach
oben kommt eher schlechter aussieht er
versucht sich also mit einer vorne
verteidigung die kritischen fragen vom
leib zeigen und das darf ihm nicht
gelingen und das wird ihm heute auch
nicht liegen jetzt wollen wir gemeinsam
hinter die verschlossenen türen schauen
wenn das hier eben gerade auch in dieser
sendung angekündigt unsere reporterin
hat ja es war die sitzt jetzt live dabei
als beide tina und hier mir hier auf dem
laptop ankommt sind sie tat das kann
dass die jetzt in diesen minuten live in
hamburg fallen und genau an denen wollen
wir sie teilhaben was sagt der kanzler
jetzt genau an seinem wichtigsten tag
schauen wir einmal rein ganz genau mit
uhrzeit angaben so 10 uhr 36 das ist
nicht lange her von wem ist er über die
durchsuchung bei warburg eigentlich
informiert worden wird er da gefragt
seine antwort das weiß ich nicht mehr
und auch um 14.30 erneut ich kann mich
an konkrete ereignisse nicht erinnern er
wird gefragt nach einem telefonat mit
peter tschentscher sagte ich habe so oft
mit dem telefoniert auch da kann ich
ihnen jetzt nicht in jeder erinnerung
weitergeben dass also die sätze allein
www vergangenen schauen wir auf die uhr
10 20 minuten anschauen die jetzt gerade
in diesem untersuchungsausschuss
gefallen sind wenn man streng nimmt
chaos dürfte doch ich erinnere mich
nicht mehr einsatz sein der jetzt in
diesem untersuchungsausschuss nicht
fallen da also wie ist der film wo die
typen liefen die immer gemacht haben und
dann hat man alles vergessen ich weiß
nicht ghostbusters oder
irgendwo man gemeint war alles vergessen
und das ist für politiker natürlich
meinen black men
in black das ist sozusagen olaf scholz
als ein men in black gebracht da ja der
vergessen hat was war wir transportieren
das mal in die jetztzeit wie war das
noch mit der scholz als die ukraine
waffen bestellt hat und sich gewünscht
hat dass wir gemeinsam mit der ukraine
die verteilten die freiheit verteidigen
das muss man nachdenken da kann ich mich
nicht erinnern wie war das also das ist
ja ein vergleichbar für ein
bürgermeister in hamburg ein
vergleichbar großes ereignis einer der
berühmtesten bekanntesten bankiers der
stadt eine familie über viele jahrzehnte
angesehene hamburger bitten den ersten
bürgermeister um einen rat das ist ja
kein termin wie ich mach mal irgendwie
50 jahre kein kleingärtner siedlung am
stadtrand das ist ja ein herausragender
termin und darüber nichts mehr zu wissen
dass es sehr merkwürdig dass mit dem
peter tschentscher glaube ich ihm
guck mal wobei bei 47 millionen euro
steuer anlass für eine reiche bank in
der kaufmann stadt hamburg als
sozialdemokrat müsste man eigentlich
schon die alarmlampen an haben wann
immer das sozusagen thematisiert wird er
hat vergessen das kann man eben jetzt
glauben oder nicht vergessen hat
natürlich den großen vorteil wenn keiner
im raum ist der beweisen kann wie es
wirklich war gewinnt man mit vergessen
und das ist die strategie von olaf
scholz gnade ihm
die kritik der bürger und gnade ihm wenn
einer aufsteht und sagt aber herr scholz
das war doch so und so und übrigens
haben sie mich noch dann und dann
angerufen und das und das gesagt und die
aufzeichnungen des bankers bankiers muss
man in dem fall wahrscheinlich eher
würdiger weise er sagen deuten eher in
die richtung das ist schon sehr
detailliert war wann da die gespräche
stattfanden und mit welchem inhalt klare
worte von claus strunz vielen dank also
wir wollten die wahrheit von olaf scholz
wissen und sein abschluss wort lautet er
hege die leise hoffnung dass die
mutmaßungen und unterstellungen jetzt
ein ende nehmen so leicht wird er mit
sicherheit nicht davon kommen denn
direkt vor beginn dieses scholz verhörs
haben unsere bild reporter jan neue
details aufgedeckt gehabt neue details
aus der akte scholz nochmal
zusammengefasst
[Musik]
helen woche für kanzler oder scholz der
kanzler unter druck wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
heute stolz verhören
untersuchungsausschuss zum sogenannten
comex kanal es geht um die wahre herr
bundeskanzler erinnern sie sich endlich
sagen sie die ganze wahrheit
darum geht es der hamburger warburg bank
wurden steuer nachzahlungen in höhe von
47 millionen euro einfach erlassen
damals regierte in hamburg olaf scholz
war das wirklich nicht seine
entscheidung keine politische
einflussnahme bild hat nun exklusive
einblicke in die akte comex bekommen
beweislage ist ziemlich ziemlich dicht
es wird schwierig für den bundeskanzler
die vielen widersprüche und sein
unerklärliches schweigen und vergessen
zu erklären
erst vor einer woche hatte scholz alle
unangenehmen journalisten fragen zu
seiner rolle im konnex plendl einfach
abgebügelt auch von den 200.000 euro
schließfach seines hamburger spd
kollegen cast weist der kanzler
angeblich nicht
ich habe keinen anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft
der kanzler unter massiven druck in
einer höllenwoche finden nach seinem
unwürdigen auftritt mit dem
palästinenserpräsident abbas nachdem er
die ganze schuld für sein schweigen auf
sein sprecher show und dann habe ich wie
ich schon gesagt habe den fehler gemacht
nicht darauf zu reagieren bzw
nicht selber eine lücke zu lassen so
dass der bundeskanzler reagieren kann
doch scholz steht weiter im sturm
ausgebuht und nieder geburt bei einer
bürgersprechstunde im brandenburgischen
neuruppin
[Musik]
internationale atomenergieorganisation
zugang bekommen haben müssen zum gründe
und das wirtschaft
eine höllenwoche für den kanzler mit dem
höhepunkt heute im verhör auftritt vor
dem untersuchungsausschuss comics für
bundeskanzler scholz geht es um alles
geht für ihn um das kanzleramt es geht
für ihn um die macht und es gibt mit
möglicherweise sogar um die macht für
die sozialdemokratische partei nicht nur
in hamburg sondern in ganz deutschland
der kanzler unter druck wie nie
im doppel schon
[Musik]
jetzt ist sie bei uns nadja aswad unsere
reporterin die mit immer
untersuchungsausschuss sitzt somit dort
sitzt wo der kanzlei sich jetzt gerade
unangenehmen fragen auf der opposition
stellen muss nadja b oft ist der satz
ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern ich
weiß es nicht genau jetzt in den letzten
minuten in der letzten stunde gefallen
hallo patricia ich habe tatsächlich
gerade bei 14 mal aufgehört zu zählen da
kam die fehlende erinnerung in
unterschiedlichsten variationen zum
tragen ich kann mich nicht konkret
erinnern das weiß ich nicht das weiß ich
nicht mehr das kann ich so nicht
beantworten also wir haben gehört dass
der kanzler viele sachen nicht mehr weiß
er hat ein sehr langes eingangs
statement verlesen da hat habe ich dann
beiseite acht aufgehört zu zählen wie
viele seiten das waren die ihr
vorgelesen hat man weiß ja auch nicht
wie groß die schriftgröße letztlich war
aber er hat noch einmal sehr deutlich
gemacht er hält die comex vorgänge ganz
klar für steuerbetrug das sei nicht
rechtens gewesen das hätte er auch schon
immer so gesehen er hat auch noch einmal
sehr deutlich zurückgewiesen dass es
irgendeine art der einflussnahme gegeben
hätte hat gesagt er würde sich sehr
freuen wenn das jetzt endlich mal zur
kenntnis genommen würde weil seit
zweieinhalb jahren würde ja schon
entsprechend ermittelt und man hätte
eben nichts heraus gefunden als dann die
befragung startete durch die opposition
dabei sicher sehr lecker hier von der
cdu als erster haben fragen dran war
aber sehr schnell klar dass der kanzler
tatsächlich konkrete fragen nicht
beantworten kann dann auch schon vorher
als seine eigenen genossen von der spd
gefragt haben hat er sich sehr oft nicht
erinnern können als olaf scholz weist
die einflussnahme zurück 14 mal hat nach
seiner tat gezählt hat er gesagt er kann
sich nicht erinnern oder er weiß es
nicht naja wir bleiben dran du auch für
uns vielen dank für den moment
sehr gern
[Musik]